it's a place that symbolizes like no
other the horrors of War but also the
promise of renewal
Vladimir zielinski came to pay his
respects at Hiroshima and he said to
find Hope
sure
the pictures of ruined Hiroshima
really remind me totally remind me
and other similar settlements and towns
just the same nothing alive left all of
the buildings have been ruined
and now Hiroshima is a rebuilt City
president zielinski has spent the week
on a whirlwind tour maximizing
diplomatic support before Ukraine's
counter-offensive can begin he is now
sounding increasingly confident and
uncompromising in his demands of the
enemy
if Russia is allowed to keep even a
sliver of the territory it occupies
international law will never again apply
but the biggest news this weekend f-16s
will be sent finally to Ukraine
American-made modern fighter jets could
make all the difference in this war when
they'll be sent isn't clear and they'll
be supplied with conditions attached
says Joe Biden I have a flat Assurance
from the from zielinski that they will
not they will not use it to go on and
move into Russian Geographic territory
but wherever Russian troops are within
Ukraine and the area they would be able
to do that when it was once G7 plus
Russia Ukraine is now the honored guest
pictures that will pack a punch in
Moscow but Beijing too Russia's failure
so far in this war a clear deterrence to
China not to invade Taiwan thank you
Britain's prime minister echoing the
sentiments of his G7 allies China poses
the biggest challenge of our age to
Global Security and prosperity
they are increasingly authoritarian at
home and assertive abroad and as the G7
have showed the UK's response is
completely aligned with our allies
this is all about de-risking not
decoupling
and with the G7 we are taking steps to
prevent China from using economic
coercion to interfere in The Sovereign
Affairs of others
president zielinski's Whistle Stop
diplomacy has paid dividends heading
home now with fresh assurances from
allies his military is counter-offensive
must surely now be imminent Dominic
wagorn Sky News